The Washington Post is out with a new
piece this week casting doubt on claims
from congressman Devin Nunez and others
about mysterious Maltese professor
joseph Mifsud
having ties to western intelligence
remember miss subas at the center of the
case against george papadapolis and
while Jim Comey cast him as a Russian
agent Muller's report makes no such
claim and questions about whether or not
this hood has undisclosed ties to the
West have yet to be answered here to
respond to all of this is ranking member
of the House Intelligence Committee
Republican congressman Devin Nunez
congressman Nunez it's really great to
talk to you your work on this case um I
think when we look back on it you'll be
remembered for it you've done some
incredible work and I deeply appreciate
it having said that the core of the
conspiracy theory against Donald Trump
has been that Joseph Mifsud had some
ties to the Russian government relayed
information to trump campaign member
george papadapolis and that set off this
tide of the FBI investigatory trail but
congressman bob muller after millions of
dollars 500 search warrants multiple FBI
agents interviewing people makes no such
claim in his report he says Massoud has
Russian connections that's far different
than him being a Russian agent what are
we missing here well you know Joe you
know tan there's always this saying
where there's smoke there's fire but in
this case there's not even smoke
there's not even any ashes the fact that
Joseph misfeed who was a Maltese
diplomat before he was a professor he's
seen in pictures with people like Boris
Johnson he's leading talks at NATO he's
involved with with many US agencies
including the State Department and the
FBI and and let's just top it off with
this in early 2017 as the House
Intelligence Committee is beginning our
investigation just steps away from that
investigation
Joseph Mifsud was guess where in the US
Capitol at the invitation of the State
Department or a group associated with
the State Department members of Congress
were there so look the fact that Joseph
Mifsud knows some Russians yeah I think
that's very likely
the fact that molar ignores certain
documents that he actually uses he uses
pieces of news stories in his what I
call the molar dossier the molar report
and in those same news reports dan you
have evidence in the news report where
they call him these writers that they
thought were good enough to use for to
make one point they don't use the fact
that those writers claimed that he was a
Western intelligence asset so this whole
mr. thing has stunk for a long time it
makes no sense I have no idea whether or
not if he's a Russian asset or a Western
intelligence asset or or a double agent
or what all I know is that after 40
million dollars we still don't know any
more than we knew before and this is
supposedly the guy that knew about the
Clinton emails in congressmen what are
the suspicious pieces I found in the
Washington Post report is they go they
emphasize that length myths its efforts
to cultivate relationships with Russians
well if he was a Russian asset then why
is he cultivating relate I mean you
understand how that doesn't make it he
says so on one hand you were telling us
myth suits the key figure in a Russian
exchange of information with the Trump
team to win an election and on the other
hand in the Washington bush you're
reporting that he's still taking trips
to Russia trying to ingratiate himself
to people I mean both of those stories
can't be true at the same time well the
other weird thing about this Sudan is is
that you have the mainstream media who
got this totally wrong they were wrong
about the hoax you talked about on your
show all the time you've written a book
on it the many people that you just had
on that on just before us have talked
about this when are they just gonna give
it up like these are Russian hoaxers
like what on earth is the Washington
Post doing you know jumping back into
the Russia hoax water and I think what
they found is they look foolish again
because look the only guy that we know
that is said for sure that Mifsud is a
Russian asset is guess who James Comey
just about a month ago in the pages of
the Washington Post and so then the
Washington Post decided you know they
have all of their they're supposed
sources that they don't name I mean none
of this makes any sense but I don't
understand why the mainstream media
continues to jump into these waters why
don't they actually try to go get the
true
right they they interview what some they
interview a lady in the in the story
that's that's at one time had
affiliation she's a UK citizen
Sam Sam buyer Sam very they're saying
yeah we know the name
yeah sure Harvard they're sent back yeah
so so why do you it so clearly she knows
Mifsud right they interviewed her why
not ask her point-blank you worked with
this guy you worked the State Department
you work with the FBI in the past who is
this guy why would you not have a hold
you know two or three or four paragraphs
just interviewing her she could probably
tell you a lot on Joseph Knibb saying
coachman I just got older couldn't call
him a Russian asset I just got a few
sentence up but I just want to get this
one last question and also why isn't
there some kind of damage assessment
being done by the government if a
Russian asset Joseph stood he's been
palling around with UK intelligence he
was in the United States in February of
2017 where is the damage assessment at
this point well there that's and that's
been our major point the whole time if
Mifsud was a Russian asset my god you've
got the FBI the State Department the US
Congress all of our allies NATO Boris
Johnson I mean they've all been
compromised by this Russian asset famous
Russian asset Joseph Mifsud so look the
fact that they're not doing a damage
assessment dan I think tells you and the
American people all you need to know
highly unlikely that Mifsud is a Russian
asset congressman thanks so much for
your work on this it's really been
incredible